caitlyn long the well-known former wall
street executive and now the
entrepreneur building a brand new type
of bank in wyoming she recently was on
cnbc and they asked her what do you
think about this market crash and do you
think that we need more regulation now
caitlyn had a very unique standpoint she
said yes we need more regulation but we
actually need more clarity to prevent
the bad actors and not to distort the
market here's caitlin stating exactly
this but dewey in an ironic sort of way
need regulation and some level of
centralization in order to ensure that
that decentralized vision can play out
that's a great question and i have been
pro-regulation
with regard to enabling regulation that
prevents the fraudsters and crazy
leveraged players that burned this this
industry so badly in the last several
months
from from
regaining their position one of the
challenges is that the regulators by by
slow walking the the non-leveraged
players of which custodia is one they
didn't give the market an alternative
and into that void of of the slow
walking that happened from the
regulators filled all these fraudsters
and frankly some criminals and and
that's it
the regulators work both with action and
inaction and in this case i think their
inaction caused much greater problems
that was especially true with the sec
which green lighted the gbtc as the one
and only way that folks could gain
exposure to bitcoin in their brokerage
accounts for almost six years and that
created a an incredible market
distortion because it was a closed-end
fund that ended up trading at a big
premium to bitcoin that hurt retail
investors and all these leveraged wall
street funds could come in right and
arbitrage that and pick off the retail
investors how is that good for the
industry now i think most people when
they hear the word regulation they think
about the regulators coming in stopping
things shutting them down and preventing
the good actors from doing what they
want to do but kaitlyn's point is really
important she's basically saying the
people who are bad actors who are going
ahead and actually causing harm to folks
they should be stopped and if you go and
you look at most regulation that's at
least the intended cause of the
regulation now i think that caitlyn has
a really unique perspective here she's
not saying that there should be tons and
tons of regulation that not only slows
down bad actors and good actors she's
saying we should be thoughtful we should
try to come up with regulation that
clarifies what's in bounds and what's
out of bounds and if we did that what it
would do is it would prevent the bad
actors the people who are taking too
much risk the people who are doing
things and not disclosing them prevent
them from actually gaining more and more
traction at the same exact time what it
would allow is the good actors the
people who end up actually trying to
follow rules who tried to disclose
everything who do things that are in the
best interest of their customers
those individuals would be able to
continue to operate and then the
customers they would be easily able to
identify good actors from bad now that's
exactly what we have in the legacy
financial system whether it's increased
disclosure rules the prevention of
people taking on too much leverage or
rules around what banks and other
financial institutions can do with
deposits i think the idea of that
regulation being extended into the
bitcoin and crypto market whether market
participants like it or not it's coming
and i think that there's a lot of folks
in this new world who are learning why
there are rules in the old world and
they're learning why things like
disclosures can be so helpful in a
market hearing caitlyn talk about this
on national television is a great sign
it means that more and more people are
starting to realize and understand and
then verbally speak it into existence in
the public domain regulation is coming
whether folks like it or not things like
increased disclosures is coming whether
people like it or not
we can't sit by and expect nothing to
change after over a trillion dollars is
wiped from a market and there's tons of
contagion and lots of nefarious activity
that's been exposed as the tide has gone
out in this bear market times are
changing and it's the challenge to
investors you got to change with the
times or risk being left behind